foreign
[Music]
s actually the same thing
the biggest question the most important
question that every human can ask is
where do we go when we die
because we will all die one day
I personally believe that all the
answers are found in scripture in the
Bible
now you might be saying Daniel
right away if the god of the Bible is
real if you exist then how do you
explain all these other gods all these
other religions and what about aliens do
you believe aliens exist are we the only
intelligent life there is or are there
more on other planets
well someone once said that I don't
believe that there's intelligent life on
other planets because there's not even
intelligent life on this planet
well all right let's get to the point
the real question that you should ask
yourself is this even if these other
beings are real and have power are they
Gods aliens demons or are these beings
actually the same thing maybe people
just look at similar evidence and they
interpret it according to their beliefs
because
a man sees as he is scientists do the
same thing today they look at the same
evidence but they interpret it
differently according to Wikipedia
there's an estimated of 10 000 distinct
religions worldwide
world population review.com says there
are only around four thousand now some
of you might be asking me all right
Daniel so if Christianity is right the
Bible is true then where do all these
other thousands of religions come from
where are these Gods coming from them
well take it easy because this is what
I'm going to explain to you in this
video and to most of you it is going to
be shocking
first of all you need to know that you
don't need to study all these thousands
of religions to know if it's true or not
because when you look at all of them
it can be brought down to only three
basic groups
one only the universe exists so here you
find atheism and so on
two only God or gods exist here you find
Buddhism and so forth
lastly both the world and God exist here
you find for example Christianity Islam
and Judaism
so you don't need to be an expert on in
all these thousands of religions to
critique them you just need to critique
the one group that they fall under and
then you critique all the religions
under them now some people claim that
Christianity stole their beliefs from
other religions and these people say
this with no evidence to back it up and
they don't know what they're talking
about because it is not true
some of the evidence that they try to
show comes from the Roman Catholic
Church's belief that came later on
it is actually the other way around
other religions paganisms stole their
ideas from Christianity
Jesus Christ didn't just exist two
thousand years ago
that was when he came to Earth in human
form he was always there in the
beginning before humankind you can watch
my video on that a little bit later on
the dlm Christian Lifestyle Channel
now we can talk about this for hours so
let's go back to where this all started
where all other religions first began
there are many ancient writings about
this but let us start with the Bible
First Genesis 6 verse 4 there were
giants in the earth in those days and
also after that when the sons of God
came in unto the daughters of men and
they bear children to them the same
became Mighty Men which were of old men
are renowned the Lord saw that the
wickedness of man was great in the earth
and that every intention of the thoughts
of his heart was only evil continually
and the Lord regretted that he had made
man on the Earth
and it grieved him to his heart so the
Lord said I will blow out man whom I
have created from the face of the land
man and animals and creeping things and
birds of the heavens for I am sorry that
I have made them but Noah found favor in
the eyes of the Lord
these are the generations of Noah Noah
was a righteous man blameless in his
generation Noah walked with God and Noah
had three sons
now you might say what I didn't see
anything about starting other religions
here
well just wait a little bit let's go
back to verse four now the Old Testament
was written in Hebrew and the Hebrew
word here for Giants is Nephilim
so this group of Fallen Angels demons or
or Watchers called by other ancient
writings married human females and they
had half-break children with them many
of these mixed breeds Drew very big they
were immensely powerful and were called
the Nephilim in English the Mighty Men
of old
we know that these Giants these Mighty
Men of old or Nephilim were real not
just because we're reading the Bible but
because it's mentioned in many other
ancient writings as well in other
cultures
and some ancient writings say that these
half preach came from the line of Cain
you know Cain the first human being that
was born on Earth from Adam and Eve
he sinned against God he killed his
brother Abel and then this happened
Genesis 4 verse 16 then Cain went away
from the presence of the Lord and
settled in the land of not East of Eden
K knew his wife and she conceived and
bore Enoch when he built a city he
called the name of the city after the
name of his son Enoch to Enoch was born
Iran an irat father mahuya
then the list goes on to explain the
line of Cain many other ancient writings
say that this in the East this is the
area where the Fallen Angels Came Down
they married the woman of Earth the line
of Cain and they had these half breeds
half human half demons now the Bible
doesn't say it but it could have been
true
what we do know is that these Nephilim
did exist that they were on the Earth
most writings also explain how humans
worshiped these fallen angels and
Nephilim because they believed that they
were gods so the Nephilim ruled over
humans on Earth as kings
now they also taught humans certain
crafts now just make a mental note here
because if you are if you know anything
about Illuminati it is said that if you
are in the Illuminati you are in The
Craft
I'll talk about this a little bit later
on so these Fallen Angels taught humans
these certain mysterious crafts
knowledge for example some ancient
Literature Like The Book of Enoch says
this in a summary
Fallen Angels also called Watchers began
to have sexual intercourse with women
and gave birth to Giants hundreds of
feet tall and the Giants began to devour
animals and Men even drinking their
blood the Fallen Angels taught them
crafts azazal told humans how to make
weapons and showed women how to use
their beauty for seduction armoros
thought enchantments barakuijal thought
humans astrology like horoscopes cocobel
constellations Ezekiel interpretation of
clouds a Rock Hill interpretation of
Earth and sungl lunar months now you
might not realize this but you've
probably already heard about the
Nephilim before
over Generations the names just changed
and it's packaged differently but the
Nephilim you've heard of that before
other cultures might call him demigods
those are the children of God supposed
gods and humans which is exactly what
the Bible says the sons of God came down
and they married the woman of Earth and
they brought forth the Nephilim there is
nothing new Under the Sun
the Greek Legends call them Titans which
you probably saw in a few movies already
for example Poseidon the god of the sea
married a human female just like we see
in the Book of Genesis Plato for example
wrote about this he said Poseidon and
his wife had children five sets of twins
and these children were Titans who
became the kings of the Atlantean Empire
now Plato did not write about this as a
Methodist story he was serious that's
why people are still searching for the
lost city of Atlantis to this day and we
have these stories of these mixed breeds
these Giants from all cultures over all
the world like the Anunnaki that we read
about in the Sumerian history from
around 4500 years ago these Anunnaki
also became the Kings or rulers over the
Sumerians we see this in the history of
the Greeks as well for example Heracles
AKA Hercules son of Zeus and the Mortal
women outmin
Perseus son of Zeus and a human woman
Danae and you find more than 30 other
demigods here in Greek history as well
in Norse history for example shamagar
and other demigods
shaminger was the son of Odin and the
Mortal human woman Queen skate the list
just goes on and you'll find stories of
these Nephilim these demigods in Hindu
mythology my Native American Irish
Polynesian Roman African Sumerian and
others it all started in the pre-flood
period also called by a lot of people
today as the anti-diluvian period
these people worshiped these fallen
angels and their half breeds as Gods
because they were so powerful and
because they were so big
some might have been smaller but still
look a little bit different because they
were mixed breeds so people today modern
people when they look at them they would
probably think they are aliens because
they all look so very different and
strange
so do aliens exist well you're a half
right because there are other beings
that are not human
in those times they were real
fallen angels and also these mixed
breeds today there are also demons so
aliens are not beings from other planets
but from other dimensions there's a
whole spiritual world that we know
exists millions of people talk about it
we include it and these beings can
reveal themselves to people you call
them maybe aliens but we know in fact
that they are demons the idea of aliens
is demon-made to deceive people from
finding the real truth demons can easily
shape-shift and appear to humans in a
physical form if they want to when we
look in the Bible we also see that
Angels appear to humans in a physical
form when they needed to more on this
later some ancient writings also
indicate that strange beings like
Centaur siren cyclopsis and other half
man half beasts were some of these
Nephilim now the Bible doesn't say this
so I'm not fully convinced but these
stories could have come from this time
period of these Nephilim where the
Nephilim walked the Earth and people saw
them you need to understand that in the
pre-flood period in the antediluvian
period there were Advanced civilizations
human beings living together with these
fallen angels that came down to marry
the the woman and have these mixed
breeds so imagine this world and they
were part of the reason why the world
became so evil because remember right
after the Bible talks about them it says
this in verse 5 the Lord saw that the
wickedness of man was great in the earth
and that every intention of the thoughts
of his heart was only evil continually
now if you believe in aliens
you would probably believe that these
beings are aliens if you would teleport
for example just quickly in that time
and you would see these Nephilim and
these Fallen Angels then you would
probably just think man they are aliens
because that's what you believe
right this is probably what aliens would
believe would look like because you
don't know what true angels and demons
look like because you never had that
experience
and when we look at certain angels in
the Bible when the Bible describes them
they also look pretty weird it's not
just these cheesy aliens that we
sometimes see on TV Ezekiel describes
four angels that he saw
Ezekiel 1 says they had human likeness
but four wings each one had four faces
the legs were straight and the soles of
their feet were like The Souls of a
calf's foot they sparkled like burnished
bronze and under the wings they had
hands like humans
now you probably heard about the angel
Gabriel Daniel saw him and he describes
him in Daniel 10.
I lifted up my eyes and looked and
behold
a man clothed in linen with a belt of
fine gold from hufas around his waist
his body was like Barrel his face like
the appearance of lightning his eyes
like flaming torches his arms and legs
like The Gleam of burnished bronze and
the sound of his words like the sound of
a multitude
not all the angels look the same not all
the demons look the same so you can just
imagine some ancient writings say that
this certain group of Fallen Angels who
came down and married the woman of the
earth they had Viper snake-like faces so
you can just imagine how these mixed
breeds that they created looked like
the Bible does not tell us but the
agnostic writings describe them as
having long protruded chins high
cheekbones elongated skulls and slanted
eyes
now this sounds like what you know as
this is probably an alien well no it's
Nephilim and we see this in the art that
they drew even thousands of years later
even in Egypt we see some of this take a
look at this Egyptian art from Queen
Nefertiti and Pharaoh Akhenaten they
still have these snake-like faces even
thousands of years after the original
Nephilim were created from different
cultures we also see these different
serpent
lizard looking Gods with wings
quartzikoto is the serpent god of the
Aztecs sometimes also drawn as a dragon
which you can get when you put a serpent
together with wings
wajet is the Egyptian cobra goddess Rena
nutsed is another Egyptian goddess at
times with the head of a lion but is
also known in the Underworld to take the
shape of a huge serpent that breathes
fire the habikau is the son of the
goddess reninated and he is a giant
snake guarding the entrance of the
underworld
the theme of these ancient serpent gods
that were Eternal is everywhere if you
just look their symbol is everywhere
in ancient Greece we have for example
the Gorgons three female serpent Gods
known as Steno yuriel and Medusa
in Hinduism there are the nagas half
serpent gods that can take the form of
snakes or humans you also get Garuda the
eagle type God in Australia we have the
rainbow creation serpent God in Norse
history we have German Gander the big
snake coiled around the earth with the
demon wolf femurer as his brother and
Hell the goddess of death as his sister
it is his Venom that supposedly kills
Thor in Celtic worship we have the snake
goddess quora and now just after the
flood in the time of the Sumerians we
find ningijida his symbol is the
twisting serpent figure the god of
Agriculture and the underworld
is another example this is the serpent
God on the Ishtar gate of Babylon the
Anunnaki they are also known as Eagles
or Ravens look I can go on and on
because it does go on and on but if you
look at all these real religions and how
they started they have the same theme
Gods came down
had sexual intercourse with women of
Earth and they created demigods you see
that in all the cultures
like even the nagas of Hinduism that
created demigods with human females
these are the fallen angels that came
down and slept with the women of Earth
and created the Nephilim that's where it
started in
imagine just this world in the
anti-diluvian period where you have all
these fallen angels and you have these
Giants Harvard mixed breeds and people
worship them as Gods imagine how evil
the world was because it was evil
imagine the rape murder human sacrifices
and rituals that were going on and on
and God said it's enough
he washed it all away with the flood
now these Nephilim will still on the
earth After the flood
the blood was highly deluded they
weren't as big and as strong as they
used to be before the flood but we know
that other ancient writings wrote that
they existed After the flood and also
the Bible Genesis 6 verse 4 says the
Nephilim were on the earth in those days
meaning Before the Flood and also
afterward
now we don't know exactly how they still
continue to live after the flood because
the flood killed everyone there's a few
ancient writings that say different
things but the Bible doesn't really tell
us it could have been that the line of
the Nephilim came through one of Noah's
sons the one of the women that they
married probably the lion of kush and
through Nimrod I'll explain that a
little bit later on it could also have
been that some of those those groups of
uh Fallen Angels still slept with some
of the women and got stopped it because
Jude 1 verse 6 says and the angels who
did not stay within their own position
of authority but left their proper
dwelling he has kept an eternal change
under gloomy Darkness until the Judgment
of the great day so this is why we don't
have Nephilim today anymore because this
certain group of Fallen Angels they are
now chained
in utter Darkness they're there right
now while you're watching this video the
fact is that we see evidence of the
Nephilim in the time period After the
flood as well there's a lot of evidence
for this we see this when Israel escaped
Egypt and entered into the promised land
for example numbers 13 32 so they
brought to the people of Israel a bad
report of the land that they had spied
out saying the land through which we
have gone to Spire out it is a land that
devours its inhabitants
and all the people that we saw in it are
of great height and there we saw the
Nephilim the sons of anak who come from
the Nephilim and we seem to ourselves
like Grasshoppers and so we seemed to
them
here are a few more examples King OGG
during the time of The Exodus
Deuteronomy 3 verse 11 for only OGG the
king of Bashan was left of the remnant
of the rephire behold his bed was a bed
of iron is it not in rabba of the
ammonites nine cubits was its length and
four cubits its breadth according to the
common qubit the refiam here is the
descendants of the Nephilim some ancient
writings some people say that it's part
of the the kingly Nephilim but it was a
bed of iron here because a normal bed
could not have contained this massive
body the bed was between 13 and 16 feet
tall that's over four meters long so OG
was a giant many years later we read
about David who fought Goliath that's
famous you know it's even in normal
stories these days
but Goliath was a lot smaller than Ogg
and Goliath was not the only giant he
had brothers and there were others as
well one Chronicles 20 verse 5 and there
was again war with the Philistines and
El hanon the son of jire struck down
lakhmi the brother of Goliath the guitar
the shaft of whose spear was like a
Weaver's beam that's huge and 2 Samuel
21 16 says
one of the descendants of the Giants who
spear weighed 300 shekels of bronze and
who was armed with a new sword thought
to kill David but abhishai the son of
zarui came to his Aid and attacked the
Philistine and killed him Verse 18 after
this there was again war with the
Philistines at Gob then sibikai the
hishatai struck down sup who was one of
the descendants of the Giants and there
was again war with the Philistines at
God and ilahanan the son of jari Oregon
the bethlehemite struck down bellay of
the gitite the shaft of whose spear was
like a Weaver's beam this was a
different Goliath verse 20 and there was
again War at gath where there was a man
of great stature who had six fingers on
each hand and six toes on each foot 24
in number and he also was descended from
the Giants and when he had taunted
Israel Jonathan the son of shimei
David's brother struck him down
these four were descended from the
Giants in God and they fell by the hand
of David and by the hand of his servants
six fingers and six toes interesting
right because they were half breeds but
remember this was many years after the
flood after the antediluvian period and
so the DNA was highly diluted so they
weren't as big as the original Nephilim
in the anti-delivian period some ancient
writing says that they were between 20
and 60 feet and some say even more than
100 feet it might be a little bit of a
stretch but they were big they were huge
and after the flood there were still
many of them left whole tribes and plans
of them we read in Deuteronomy 2 verse
20. it is also counted as a land of
refiam refiam formally lived there but
the ammonites called them zamzum
a people great and many and tall as the
anakum but the Lord destroyed them
before the ammonites and they
dispossessed them and settled in their
place
Joshua 11 and verse 21 and Joshua came
at the time and cut off the anakam from
the Hill Country from Hebron from the
bird from anav and from all the Hill
Country of Judah and from all the Hill
Country of Israel Joshua devoted them to
destruction with their cities so they
had many cities there were many of them
Deuteronomy 2 verse 11 like the anakam
they are also counted as refine but the
moabites called them em the evidence of
the Nephilim has always been there
take some time and look at the evidence
of non-biblical writers like Jewish
historians like Josephus and Philo then
the second temple literature The Book of
Giants The Book of Enoch and so forth
so let me quickly summarize here so we
know that Fallen Angels Came Down they
slept with the woman of Earth and they
created the Nephilim right we see this
from all cultures different cultures
that say that these supposed Gods came
down slept with the woman of Earth and
they created demigods Nephilim so all of
it proved that the Bible is true and
this world became extremely evil so God
washed it all away with a flood and yes
for some of you don't believe that there
was a flood I'm going to show you the
evidence of a flood in the next video
we're going to talk about that and it's
going to be very interesting now only
Noah his three sons and their wives
survived the flood
that's what the Bible says the Bible
says in Genesis 9 verse 18 the sons of
Noah who went forth from the ark were
Shem and yapeth ham was the father of
Canaan these three were the sons of Noah
and from these the people of the whole
earth were dispersed
so Noah was a righteous man he believed
in God his family as well so they
brought all of this knowledge from the
pre-flood world with them remember this
this is important
they had all the knowledge of how to
build certain things where the old
cities were the locations of them and
now where do all the other religions
come in again
we see this from the one son of Noah ham
from the line of ham we see that people
start to disobey God again just like the
pre-flood world
and they started to do paganism Pagan
worship now let me just say this again
Christianity is true the Bible is true
because it's a truth of life itself
paganism only started later so shame's
children will bring forth the nation of
Israel and Jesus the Messiah japwev's
children became the Coastland cultures
each of their own language Clan and
nation and then Ham's children will
bring forth Disobedience to God again
just like before the flood hisons are
called Kush Egypt put and Canaan so
Ham's firstborn is Kush
rebelled against God God wanted him to
worship him because God wants all humans
to worship and love him but Kush
rebelled he didn't want to he went off
to do his own thing according to his own
fleshly desire sinful desires he created
his own Clan and he wanted to rule
people and that's what he did and now
Kush is the father of nimrod now this is
where it gets very interesting chapter
10 verse 8 Kush fathered Nimrod he was
the first on the earth to be a Mighty
Man verse 9 he was a mighty Hunter
before the Lord therefore it is said
like Nimrod a mighty Hunter before the
Lord the beginning of his kingdom was
bubble Iraq akat and kalne in the land
of shinar from that land he went into
Assyria and built ninephi Rehoboth ear
kala and risen between ninephi and kala
that is the great City now just remember
here again so Nimrod was the first
Mighty Man again after the flood
remember Genesis 4 talks about the
Mighty Men of old
the Nephilim were on the earth in those
days and also off to it when the sons of
God came into the daughters of man and
they bore children to them these were
the Mighty Men Who were of old the men
of renown
so biblical texts and other ancient
writings show us that Nimrod was a huge
guy I mean he was big with the size and
the Superhuman strength people would
have easily followed him as their leader
and that's why he created all these
cities so some of the DNA of the
Nephilim came through the line of ham
probably through his wife and cushion
then you get Nimrod and we also know
about his other sons and that's where
you get the the nations from Canaan and
Egypt where in Canaan you know when the
Israelites went there there were the
Giants
the Bible describes them as the refiam
so listen up because this is going to be
very interesting because this is where I
believe most of paganism as we know it
today and even the Illuminati started
did you know that the Illuminati calls
Nimrod the first Grand Master
at the top level of the order the
Illuminati worships Satan directly and I
still do so today
Nimrod built Babel and he was the first
world government in a sense and we can
assume that the Tower of Babel was also
his doing ancient writings describes how
Nimrod built the Tower in Rebellion
against God so the the whole Tower is in
Rebellion against God some people do it
even today and you can see the marks of
the Illuminati in the world that we live
in today as well Nimrod wanted to do it
so that God could not kill them again
with the flood but he missed the crucial
lesson of why God
flooded the whole earth in the
antediluvian period because they did not
repent of their sins and so Nimrod did
not learn his lesson and those who
followed him did not learn their lesson
as well according to the historian
Josephus
Nimrod said he would be revenged on God
if he should have a mind to drown the
world again for that he would build a
tower too high for the waters to reach
and that he would avenge himself on God
for destroying their forefathers
Antiquities of the Jews book 1 chapter
4. now at this time these people started
to worship Nimrod himself as a God and
also other supposed Gods fallen angels
and Nephilim according to Josephus
Nimrod convinced the people to not
believe that they got their strength and
everything from God himself but that
they should find their own happiness and
their own strength from themselves so in
this period you start to get paganism
Witchcraft and all these other occultic
stuff that started here and so it was
kind of repeating itself the world
that's why God had to stop the world in
the first place because of the Nephilim
and everybody there just being Wicked
and now that the same thing started to
happen again but God promised that he
will not send a flood again over the
world so what did he do while they were
building the Tower of Babel he confused
them because they had the same language
so he gave them different languages
then they said come let us build
ourselves a city and a tower with its
top in the heavens
and let us make a name for ourselves
lest we be dispersed over the face of
the whole earth and the Lord came down
to see the city and the tower which the
children of man had built and the Lord
said behold they are one people and they
have all one language and this is only
the beginning of what they will do
so imagine if he just left them how evil
the world would have been
and nothing that they propose to do will
now be impossible for them come let us
go down and there confuse their language
so that they may not understand one
another's speech so the Lord dispersed
them from there over the face of all the
earth and the left of building the city
therefore its name was called Bible
because there the Lord confused the
language of all the Earth and from there
the Lord dispersed them over the face of
all the Earth
so here when God dispersed them of
course they would take all their beliefs
and things with them and they would
start Nations this is where paganism
really started and Nimrod was wrong no
man is stronger than God life itself is
a gift from him and he can take it away
any time that he wants but he gives us
Grace a time of Grace to find him to
worship him and to love him to find the
truth for ourselves and to live in that
truth
now what is interesting and you would
think that all these different people
who started to go in disperse of all the
Earth that they would have stories of
nimrod right
they do Nimrod appears in a mythology of
a lot of the ancient cultures in Greek
in Arabic Hungarian Armenian and Syrian
Legends there's evidence that the Epic
of Gilgamesh and the story of Hercules
are both based on nimrod's life
so let's just move back to when God
dispersed him so these people took their
beliefs with them and that's where
paganism started paganism came from
Christianity actually it just distorted
and these people just took their beliefs
with them paganism was created by demons
so that people will believe in the
demons as gods and not in the real true
and Only God and if you believe in all
these demons you ultimately believe in
Satan so people say you have all these
roads that lead up to the mountain and
all the religions are basically the same
no
it is fundamentally different there's
only one way one truth that leads to
Jesus Christ
all the other roads lead to different
demons and ultimately Satan and that's
what he wants because he wants to be as
God that's why he is a fallen angel that
rebelled against God in the first place
he looked at himself in his Beauty and
he thought I am mighty so you know what
I want to be God now let me share
something that's also very interesting
keep in mind this is not from the Bible
so I'm not 100 sure if this is correct
but it could be this is from many other
ancient writings and people today
believe in other ancient writings easily
more than I believe in the Bible even
though the Bible
is the best source of ancient writings
that we have
um if we look at all the copies of
ancient literature the Bible is number
one we can put the Bible together in its
original form from over 60 000 copies
many ancient writings say that Nimrod
used the seven sacred Sciences to gain
power the same crafts given to Men by
the Fallen Angels before the flood men
like Enoch so after that period of the
flood Nimrod again finds this knowledge
and he uses it again and the world
becomes more evil so history repeats
itself
remember I told you the beginning of
this video that the Fallen Angels gave
certain crafts and knowledge of certain
things to humans not for good but to do
sin and now Nimrod has this knowledge
and he is doing the exact same thing I
don't have time to talk about everything
but let me give you a few bullet points
Hermes shared the pre-flood knowledge
with Nimrod some say Hermes is a
Nephilim others are Fallen Angel and
others say that he is a name combined of
the three different individuals Before
and After the flood who all carried the
knowledge of demon crafts a type of
spirit of Hermes that goes on through
different Generations
nemrod uses the knowledge to build Babel
and the big tower to honor the gods AKA
demons as they did in the anti-deluvian
time the tower symbolizes Rebellion
against God
Hermes uses the crops to create the
priesthood of polytheism meaning
worshiping demons as gods that were set
up in the pre-flood period this is a
Nephilim Wizard or magic type of
religion where they talk to or report to
these gods
AKA demons
so now after Nimrod died a lot of people
say that his wife say me ramus I think
that's how you pronounce it she took
over now there are different stories
about her but there's one that's very
interesting to me and you find it in
different sources a good book that
explains it is a book of 1853 called The
Two Babylons and it basically says this
Shem and his followers wanted to stop
Nimrod and his evil deeds and killed him
now for his wife samiramis she claimed
the Virgin birth that the demons knew
would happen with Jesus
so you see basically claimed this virgin
birth that the demons at that time knew
would happen with Jesus do you see how
Sly these demons are Shem the other son
of Noah and his followers wanted to stop
in Nimrod and his evil deeds and killed
him remember Shem he's the great great
great grandfather of the nation of
Israel those who follow God
so you have Nimrod they worshiped as a
father God you have semi-ramas that they
worshiped as the mother God and now you
have the sun god that they also started
to worship sounds familiar doesn't it
polytheism and many Pagan religions have
this same theme the exact same theme
that's where they start a mother God a
father God and a sun god semi ramas
claimed that Nimrod did not really die
but ascended to the Sun and became the
Sun God and the Rays of the sun god
caused her to become pregnant and they
have to worship him now as ball the sun
god and remember they also have to
worship her because she was the Goddess
that was divinely created she said she
is the moon goddess who came down from
the Moon in a moon egg that fell into
the Euphrates River so this queen of
Babylon basically became the moon
goddess called Ishtar istarte or
asterath which many people believe is
where we get our Easter from now this is
probably the same Queen of Heaven that
we read about in Jeremiah 44 16. as for
the word that you have spoken to us in
the name of the Lord we will not listen
to you but we will do everything that we
have vowed make offerings to the Queen
of Heaven and pour out drink offerings
to her as we did both we and our fathers
hmm
her son's name was born damus this new
God born on the winter the day of the
winter solstice interesting isn't it now
he was believed to be killed by a wild
pig and then he ascended to his father
the son God and they became one
so these people who continue to worship
them they stayed there and kept on
worshiping them and we see this first
mysterious religion here of worshiping
the father God the mother God and the
sun god and this weird religion of
Babylon started to spread in into other
countries like Egypt Persia and Greece
and over time we see the same story just
packaged and just using different names
for example Babylon followed Nimrod the
sun god semiramus the mother God and
tamuse the sun god nordics follow Odin
the father God joro the mother God and
Thor the sun god Egypt follows ra the
sun god Isis the mother God and Horus
the sun god
Rome follows the father God Jupiter the
mother God Diana and the son god Apollo
Hinduism follows the father God Vishnu
the mother God Chandra and the reborn
son God Krishna Greece follows the
father God Zeus and the mother God
Artemis and the sun god Adonis now we
know that in paganism there can be many
other gods as well but when you look at
the core there is always a mother god
father God and a sun god
and for those of you who are Roman
Catholic you also need to hear this
Roman Catholics also brought this in
when they started to worship Mary as the
mother God
if you pray to or worship Mary
then you need to know that this is
paganism
nowhere in the Bible does it say that we
have to pray to Mary
actually God forbids it that we pray to
dead people and it clearly says that
Jesus Christ is the only mediator
between God and Men you should not even
pray to the Saints that's paganism now
the point I'm slowly trying to make in
this whole video is this there's enough
evidence that shows us that there are no
aliens or other gods
that there's only one God
all the other ones are demons pretending
to be Gods because they are powerful
because they are real and because they
were Netflix as well in the old days
where we get all these ancient stories
from and even to this day people worship
other demons thinking that they are
other gods and I say this to you with a
lot of love
ask yourself is this true the Bible said
thousands of years ago in Deuteronomy 32
verse 14.
they stirred him to jealousy with
strange Gods with Abominations they
baroked him to anger they sacrificed to
Demons that were no Gods to gods they
had never known to New Gods that had
come recently whom your fathers had
never dreaded
all of this started thousands of years
ago in the antediluvian period
where Fallen Angels left their proper
domain and slept with the women of Earth
and created the Nephilim in where they
deceived people to believe that they
were gods and that their half-breed were
Gods as well and people worshiped them
as such even after the flood as well and
these Nephilim and then these Fallen
Angels ruled over these nations like the
Anunnaki in the Sumerian time around
4500 before Christ Chaya of the Indio
the Zoras the Tengu of the Japanese the
isobalba of the Kisha Maya and it goes
on and on you will find the same stories
these are different names in different
cultures and how interesting is it that
is the same stories but these cultures
they were thousands of miles kilometers
away from one another and at different
time periods but it is still the same
I'll say it again there is nothing new
Under the Sun now demons are powerful
they do have power and they can
shape-shift and they can reveal
themselves to you in a physical form
pretending to be some God and you think
that they are
Paul talked about this thousand two
thousand years ago one Corinthians 10
verse 19. what do I imply then that food
offered to Idols is anything or that an
idol is anything no I imply that what
pagans sacrifice they offer to demons
and not to God I do not want you to be
participants with demons
and this is exactly what happened not
only did the demons deceive people
outside of the truth and just basically
full on rebelled against God but they
started to deceive people who were
within the truth to show them another
truth it was always polytheism versus
monotheism many gods versus one God but
now they take monotheism versus
monotheism meaning they're giving people
another truth of monotheism let me
explain 2 Corinthians 11 verse 14 says
and no wonder for even Satan disguises
himself as an angel of Light
so it is no surprise if his servants
also disguise themselves as Servants of
righteousness their end will correspond
to their deeds it is easy for demons to
pretend to be Angels it is easy for
Satan to disguise himself as the angel
of Light and you know this is one thing
that when you look at history that
people who worship these other pagan
gods they never realized that the father
God they worshiped whether it is Baal
raw Zeus Jupiter Odin Vishnu or any
other form of this father God
his real name is Lucifer the devil he
was one of the highest ranking angels in
heaven but he wanted to be as God and so
he rebelled he fought against God's
angels and
he lost so God threw him down on Earth
and he's now still walking around on
earth like a lion roaring looking who he
can devour
he wanted to be like God and he started
with eve since then he deceived human
beings to lure them away from the truth
now as I said they got a plan to deceive
people within monotheism to give them
another monotheism religion right we see
people when we look at history who
thought that they saw an angel of the
Lord this Angel gave them New
Revelations and they felt so special and
they write this they wrote this
Revelations down but when we look closer
we see that these people
acted strangely foaming of the mouth
being thrown down by the Angels some
even gripped here in the neck forcefully
I mean that doesn't sound like God's
loving Angels it sounds similar right
like the video that I just explained to
you in the previous part of this whole
series of what demon possession looks
like
but these people follow these supposed
Angels AKA demons
to give a new theory of the truth for
example a supposed Angel called Moroni
appeared to Joseph Smith a few times in
the 1800s and told him that all the
other churches are not following the
real Faith anymore and that Joseph has
been chosen
to restore the real Christian faith so
this Angel gave him New Revelations and
Joseph Smith started the Mormon faith
which is actually called The Church of
Jesus Christ of the Latter-Day Saints
you'll see that their teachings is in
contrast with the original Bible another
example
is Islam I suppose that angel called
Gabriel appeared to Muhammad in a cave
and Cave him New Revelations over a
period of time people saw him as well on
the floor lying around foaming in the
mouth and he was actually afraid they
also know about when he was younger
about seeing Gins ginsen in that culture
Jesse knows basically another word for
demons
but he was actually scared out of his
mind he ran away and then he came back
later anyway he was illiterate and
people helped him to write down what
this supposed angel demon told him now
demons as we already discussed in the
previous video
can let you experience occultic and
strange things so they can appear as
Angels right deceive you but they can
also let you experience occultic things
so where do you think these things of
spiritualism or chakras and opening up
your third eye come from let's take
Buddhism for example
godama was a prince he followed Hinduism
and then he stopped believing in
Hinduism he thought man I can't agree
with this so he walked away first he
starved himself almost to death they
said that he could touch his tummy here
and feel the backbone and he almost died
there were three friends that followed
him and when he walked away they were
kind of angry at him but then he found
this tree and he thought man I'm going
to sit under this tree until I find
truth and so he wanted to open himself
up to everything that is out there to
tell him truth
so that's what he did
so don't you think that a demon could
easily have just come because he opened
himself up to all things there
to give him a special Revelation Nirvana
a special level of enlightenment
and still Buddhists can experience it
today
where do you think it comes from
could it have been a demon and still
demons today of course it can
even if the feeling is good and it's
nice and you like it then
you have to look deeper than that
because as long as they keep you away
from the truth they're happy
it's actually a lot more that I can talk
about this but we don't have time let's
take Hinduism which doesn't really have
a start date because it's a religion
that started to exist over many years
with different ideas and stories all put
together and it changed over time
there's nothing concrete about this if
you look into this
you'll see that there's so many holes
and some of you who are watching this
video might be a Hindu and I am telling
you this out of love because I care for
you just ask yourself do you really
believe that it is true after everything
I've said is it possible that some of
these other gods
are actually demons pretending to be
gods
of course it is if you've watched the
previous video of demon possession
you know that my dad and I later on
helped him to Free People of demon
possession and a lot of that came from
people who followed other religions
there was one woman who he helped who
had a demon Carly in her with the tongue
coming out and everything now people say
that all roads lead to the same God
no it doesn't that's what the devil
wants you to believe
Jesus Christ here's the truth the way
and the light
and the light no one comes to God the
Father except through him every other
Road leads directly to Satan worship and
ultimately hell for all eternity which
has been prepared for Satan and his
demons and those who worship and do
their will
now apart from giving you other
religions what other attack do you think
the devil can make on the truth just so
you don't find the truth
some of you already had doubts when I
talked about certain events in the Bible
like the flood some of you think man the
flood didn't happen
because evolution is true isn't it
that's another lie of Satan and those
who push Evolution down your throat in
school and even in entertainment they
don't want you to know everything
especially what I've told you about the
pre-flood world because they don't want
you to know that it was real so they are
brainwashing people to believe in
evolution instead of believing the Bible
because the Bible says that there was a
pre-flood world
civilizations with cities and then there
was a flood but they don't want you to
believe that because if you believe that
then you will probably believe that the
rest of the Bible is true as well
and this is exactly what we're going to
talk about in the next video I'm going
to give you evidence that there was a
flood and also evidence that we're
finding in his last few decades about
pre-flood civilizations it's going to be
very interesting so if you haven't
subscribed yet please do so now so you
won't miss that video and before you go
always remember
life is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys